yo stop down
there down there stop I swear to God
down there
stop sit down here babeo cop's looking
for you stop come here here stop babe
babe help I'm going out there in front
ofont of help babe help babe help babe
help me you're under rest that for what
for what babe help me babe help oan I'm
out with her in front of the four
dealership stop put your hands behind on
your back okay okay babe help me you're
make this way worse for yourself I'm not
biting do anything you're make this way
worse for yourself can I get get up
please quick please I can't breathe
please good turn around let me get up
please quick let get up please
quick you're making this way worse
yourself
yeah she was pulling from me I was walk
upale
on you have on
what name
Hanah
yes where are you coming from Marshalls
Marshalls yeah where else Marg Marg
Marshalls and I went Sierra my fiance
was at Target that's that's you're
looking for wearing a white shirt and
and gray shorts telling you she was they
said a female yeah that's her it's it's
it's a female she has short hair white
shirt red hand
another that's some yeah that's what I'm
out now she's down there I swear to God
she's down
there I just that's where I was going I
was telling you that she's down there
okay yeah but when I told you to stop
you started running away from her she I
scared okay nothing I I went to the to
Marshall she's looking for her no reason
I know but I'm you know that you don't
for me looking for her car around here
yeah pull pull it in the park and I'll
walk her over you got any warrants no
nothing you know of no I don't where you
from Bren County what are you doing down
here um I'm living down here right now
because I'm I'm
homeless so I'm living down in there
with my fiance and my and my friend
what's your fiance's name her name is
Catherine Catherine W um last name is
handerson h n d e r s o n she's right
down there in the room that's who I I
heard her 105 I heard her calling for
the woman outside of Target calling for
her and I told her just to stop and like
just stop but she kept going but you
were looking for me you're looking for
her for real oh we can't run regardless
I understand I wasn't strong I was it is
what it is now right
y she's it's she's she's upstairs you
have any before no I have nothing on
me what's in here a lighter
lighter turn around face
me all right have a
seat that's that's not from
Target for this man I have I I have an
email receipt in my phone
okay where's your phone at I'm hood of
my
truck
so she's
saying started run away she's saying at
the other one we're looking for her
fiance which is another
female number 105 104 describe call but
I wasn't go out with her cuz they said
short hair no that's why was like that's
why I was like get her first get watch
the video and see what the other one's
involvement is get a look at her and
then is over there but for now you can
probably just take her in well she has a
black bag for a short too so all right
we turn that back over
yeah saying that I guess there's stuff
in her
she but put your feet in the car for
right
now over
there yeah bring it all and see what see
what she paid for and paid for put the
phone with her that other stuff is
that's hers right she said she has a
receipt on the phone you want to uncover
let her pull it up up I highly doubt
it's going to be there but you never
know it could be completely
wrong what's your name what's your name
again I forgot I'm sorry Han and your
other one Catherine is that we said
Catherine with the K yeah Catherine with
a K and you're Hannah Hannah yeah Hannah
do you want to show us your receipt I
mean I'll be honest with you everything
over there it's like a casino we're
going to find out what you stole and
what you didn't stole if you're lying to
us that there's a receipt on here it's
not going to do you any good either way
it it's over at this point so do you
really have a receipt on here or do you
not have a receipt on here I have a
receipt for for part of them and not all
of them I'll be honest with you all
right all right so there is certain
things that you paid for and certain
things that you didn't yes all right all
right do you want do you want to pull
that up you don't have to show us I'm
just going to be honest with you it's up
to you we're we're going to go to the
store and we're going to find out just
going to scan in they're going to tell
us what was taking it wasn't it'll just
speed things along if if you want to
show us but it's totally your decision
we're not going to go in your phone
unless you gave us consent okay well
I can show you what wasn't what was if
you want no that's all right okay that's
we'll hold off we'll just take over
there we'll just go all over there at
least you're being honest though I app I
appreciate it I know I know I got you I
got you it's not the end of the world
all right just she doesn't have IDE on
the region that's the other thing I'm
sure we'll find out yeah yeah from say
Burlington or Burg the video you bring
her in
start all right
I only anything else briefly patted her
down with the back of my hands it's just
the lighter but I mean she's got skin
tight clothes no weapons for sure right
I I don't think so no I didn't I mean I
didn't check the waistband and all that
but like all right well what we can get
her out again and just make double make
sure do you have anything on you any
weapons something like that we're take
you back
out other offic here now turn around I'm
just going to listen I'm just going to
pat down way okay
okay all right have a SE back in
there she's got no ID on her how do you
how do you pronounce your last name
again pend p a p n d
i just lean back I
got
all right sit tight and no that's your
knowledge no warrants no sit
tight you ever been arrested for
shoplifting um a while
ago like 10 years ago um I had I went
and F out paperwork for public defender
yesterday you went to what I went to
Neptune and filled out paperwork for a
public defender yesterday for something
for a charge which I didn't get I didn't
get arrested
for um I'm waiting to see the judge for
that I had to I have court for that in
December um for a shop open yeah but
that's from I didn't get arrested for it
I saw the judge via Zoom last week and
she said you have until Thursday to fil
paper for a public defender and then we
go from there and I went and did that
yesterday but I haven't been charged
with anything like it yet but like I
said I didn't even get arrested for I
have him shoplifted
in they said they have me on camera
doing something but I didn't actually
get like like an officer didn't come and
pick me up is what I'm trying to tell
you since
2013 yeah you're going to get more
charges CU you you were resistant so I
know sir I really wasn't I really wasn't
trying to I was just trying to tell you
that she was down there I got that but I
was trying to tell you I I I I apologize
I understand I
understand hello hey how are you good so
we got the one of the two we got the one
that had the black bag so she has
merchandise in here so she wasn't being
h% truthful with us but she said some of
that is hers that she had a receipt but
doesn't have she said it's on her phone
but she doesn't have it with her is
there way you guys can tell B she saying
she bought a few things and stole the
rest so know for sure what was taken I
mean she never goes to a register but
I'll be able to find that stuff I can
run it and find no transaction by her
yeah yeah yeah right she didn't even go
to a register today all right then she
stole it all yeah I mean if she didn't
even go to a register her go to court
and figure it out yeah yeah she told
didn't she say she had it like she went
up and paid for something yep exactly
and go to register then it's all stolen
yep all
right I'll just grab this
everything that's your item that appears
new
is
unless on
camera yep that's
definitely you said there's another
female is that who she's with or this is
who she's with okay they've been
here together at least one other time
she's been here two other
times did this one steal anything yeah
yes that's actually who we were like
physically watching today okay really
yeah she was the one we saw like this is
going to be her let me I'm just going to
put a quick description out on her that
is that a female is that like a female
female short hair yeah they're the two
that ride the bikes down the highway and
they go into Asbury and then they come
back oh really yeah
274 there she SLE all the yeah those are
the nail out right now it looks like
uh the other subject is going to be a
short white female with short
hair white T-shirt and a
backpack possibly stole some under
shirts she sucks it all brings the card
around backpack's off
everything this is what we're watching
real time yeah saw her outside going to
meet her and then I put it together like
oh I remember these two
cool one
day yeah so probably everything in here
is what she had I just want to make sure
there's no weapons or anything I'm just
goinging I found this stuff
right you want me to go with you when
you scan it just yep Mike I'm going to
walk out with her while she scans it my
device I
gave I'll follow you this
than should have got their
devices can I borrow your device real
quick just to log on to the
register I'm
not oh
I say I
myself
yeah
oh this is all from one person yes the
person uh no this is the other girl so
the one you guys were watching MH it's
the other girl who had the dark long
hair so when I was in there with Chris I
saw her
taking so the one with the backpack is
the one we don't have the merise right
but
I think we know where she is okay she's
either a sitting in the woods next to
her motel or B she's inside her room
already okay cuz I don't have a total
for that merchandise
yep
say what do you
[Music]
thinked yeah and then these look used
obviously you guys don't sell lighters
or that knife
uh
think this is like a belly button ring
or something
I all right thank
you
okay you still need the total for the
person with the backpack
yeah and then I got you a case number
too
I got I got it for you okay thank
you I thought I
had
thank you thank
you the stuff that she didn't pay for
was her her three
lighters a box knife and like a that's
like her stuff that's her that's yeah so
she's clearly
uh think she used that nice to cut
anything no no no no no I think it just
at the bottom of the
ready let this
um
just as
well be what the other one took I was
way off yeah what was the one pairs were
26 bucks so it comes to like
$144.95
sounds so we just knock on to the door
if she's there it's clear is day she's
got tattoo right here the white ad shirt
she's concealing it y
second all right it all goes under one
case number right
yep yes hello how are you good is
Catherine around who's Catherine
Catherine white girl short hair not that
I know of not that you know of not that
I know is there anyone else in there
with you no not that I know of I just
got in here I was next door so okay is
this just take a quick look we're just
looking for I can't give you permission
to do that is this your place no it's
not my place who place is it it's
a1's it's a1's who's A1 he's a good
friend of mine okay but I can't give you
permission okay
right you know where the girl with short
hair does she stay here or stay I don't
know all right all right see I just
here's the thing there's a minor thing
that happened uh we're just trying to
end it right now otherwise we got to put
a warrant out for her she's going to go
right to the county jail a little thing
if she's here boom boom boom summons on
her way but we don't find her today she
War she goes right to jail so you all
right okay I just we just got to leave
this a little bit you can you can close
it right
there
what does she do what do she
do I mean if she's not like family we
can't really say but I can tell you for
sure that it's it's a minor thing
disorderly person's thing not the end of
the world I think she knows
hi Catherine how are
you want to put that down thank you for
coming out we appreciate you down make
sure you do anything good just a minor
thing at Target you know what it's about
you have any drugs or anything on you
that's going to hurt me poke me nothing
nothing nothing all
right good Cas yep so we just want to
ask you a question where's the bag that
you took that we saw on camera where
back here where over here back in
by the over there by the dealership by
the dealership if I drove you over there
could you show me where you threw it I
mean kind of I do everything like I
threw it Loose yeah
okay I didn't want to be caught with it
okay just put your hands together like
you're
praying you have any warrs Cather you
got any warrs I don't know if I've never
met you before been a before or not it's
a shop thing it's not the end of the
world we get you out in a summon you go
to court all right all
right got your appreciate your
cooperation good luck to you all
right all right we're going to walk
straight 246
o I'm going go to around the other side
damn really
yeah I have a female
41 uh
problem is you guys ran Just Hold On
Tight nobody knows what's going on it's
you know like sergeant said it's minor
so you know don't need to make a
mountain out of a mole Hiller right let
your head get in
there you have any warrants or anything
out for you no okay well things go
smoothly you'll get released on the
summon all
right
sorry do you want me to take your phone
yep to
do a second put
[Music]
this Walk This
Way